batman may be a superhero but the
batman's best scene might be one that
pauses the action and reminds him of his
own humanity warning spoilers for the
batman ahead the batman director matt
reeves vision for the caped crusader is
finally here and its grounded gritty
crime thriller approach seems to be
sitting very well with critics and
audiences alike the film places fans
early on in the story of batman his
second year fighting crime in gotham
city right at the beginning of the movie
we discover that bruce still hasn't
quite figured out exactly who he wants
to be as batman although he still seeks
vengeance on criminals for the tragedy
in his own life the batman then quickly
moves to focus on the riddler and his
one-man killing spree of gotham city
officials as batman and lieutenant
gordon frantically try to solve his
riddles and get one step ahead the
batman is filled with incredible scenes
as bruce gordon and selena kyle cross
paths with the villainous likes of
penguin and carmine falcone while
attempting to stop the riddler's plans
there are brutal fights batmobile chases
base jumping scenes and intense
conversations between batman and the
riddler although it's almost too hard to
narrow given the quality of the
action-packed and emotional scenes in
the batman there is one particular
moment that stands above the rest
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there during the
middle of the film batman and gordon
have recently discovered that bruce
wayne is the riddler's next potential
victim alfred is nearly killed in the
process and hospitalized bruce continues
his investigation while alfred heals and
a revelation from the riddler points to
his father during his mayoral campaign
seeking help from carmine falcone to
kill a journalist who is threatening to
leak a story about his wife martha's
mental health issues bruce confirms this
with carmine leading to a truly
excellent confrontation with alfred when
he wakes up from his injuries bruce
proceeds to accuse alfred of lying to
him about his parents and tells him that
he knows thomas sought out carmine that
he wasn't a good man like alfred
insisted however alfred explains that
thomas was indeed a good man albeit one
who made a poor decision in a moment of
weakness and desperation trying to
protect his family in fact thomas was
going to turn carmine into the
authorities but he and martha were
killed first bruce then pieces together
that carmine likely had his parents
killed he apologizes to alfred noting
that he felt fear for the first time in
a while knowing he could lose someone he
cares about this scene is the best in
the entire movie because the interaction
between alfred and bruce is so raw and
emotional we are able to see the bond
between two men who have gone through
immense trauma it's one of the few times
we see bruce be truly vulnerable if this
continues it won't be long before you've
nothing left
i don't care what happens to me it's no
secret that batman always has his guard
up not often are we able to truly see
bruce wayne in a vulnerable state much
less in a position where he admits to
feeling fear as that is the main tool
that he uses against those who would do
evil that's why it's so important that
we were able to witness bruce come to
the realization that he will always
still feel fear when it comes to the
people that he holds close bruce seems
to realize that fear can never truly be
eliminated only overcome this
interaction offers him a chance to slow
down and consider more of who he wants
to be who he wants batman to be and how
he wants to continue pursuing the
riddler not to mention this conversation
between alfred and bruce is truly the
only time the deaths of bruce's parents
are discussed openly alfred notes that
bruce was only a boy and although bruce
blamed himself alfred was the one who
felt responsible even explaining that he
felt like he couldn't be the father
bruce needed this scene just provides
much needed healing between two broken
characters only assisting in the
realization bruce comes to at the end of
the film about what he wants batman to
stand for although it's a close call and
there are many expertly crafted and
acted sequences in the batman this
hospital bed scene perfectly gets to the
core of bruce's struggle as both a man
and as batman
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]